we went and found something that made
him look bad blew it up had the media
all report it and then make it hurtful
to people but it was them blowing it up
then demonized me say that I was Trump's
right-hand man to demonize Trump and
then basically set the precedent that
they could take me down they could then
take everybody else down that if folks
allowed me to be taken down they also
mentioned Julian Assange in the
documents if they could shut me him down
and have the left agree with it and have
the right agree with me being shut down
it would set the president to knock down
all the dominoes so I was chosen just as
the archetype of see it's good we're
going to censor him and then as soon as
they were done with me they moved on to
everybody else